يذهب الينا من بيروت العميد الياس حنان
الخبير العسكريه والاستراتيجيه السيد
العميد كيف
يمكن ان نفهم حديث كيف عن صعوبات في جبهات
القتال
جمال هناك ديناميكيتين على الساحه
الاوكرانيه على سبيل المثال الجيش الروسي
يهاجم في خركيف وكوبيانسك والهدف منه هو
تثبيت قوات اوكرانيه وتحقيق ولكنه يدافع
على طول الجبهه الممتده 900 كيلومتر في
نفس الوقت يقصف العمق واليوم شيء جديد هو
قصف مطارات في العمق او في الغرب
الاوكرانيه تبعد 600 كيلو متر على سبيل
المثال عن خرسون هذا في الشق الروسي في
الشق الاوكراني هناك عمليه المناوره او
الحركيه فقط في مخموط ومحاوله الخرق في
ثلاث محاور اساسيه في العمق ولكن في نفس
الوقت هناك المسيرات البحريه
والمسيرات الجويه وصولا الى العاصمه موسكو
هذا هو بشكل عام
الجو العام العسكري ولكن ما قدره روسيا
على الحفاظ على مواقعها في شمال الشرقيه
اوكرانيا
في الشمال في شمال الشرقي
جمال
تقريبا هناك كثير من العسكر الروسي جمع
لمهاجمه هذه المنطقه خركاب او كوبيانس
لماذا لانه السيطره على كوبيانس ياخذنا
الى جنوبا والى كراماتورسك
وبالتالي الى مخموت وهذا الامر يعتبر جزء
حيوي واساسي وليس للجيش الاوكراني قدره
على الدفاع على طول الجبهه خاصه خلال
القيام بعمليات هجوميه لخرق الدفاعات
الروسيه
اعلن اليوم قالت جميع رؤساء مراكز التجديد
العسكري في انحاء اوكرانيا بدعوى الفساد
برايك ما هي التداعيات المترتبه على هذه
الخطوه وانعكاساتها على الموقف الميداني
في اوكرانيا
هي خطوه مهمه هي ليست للمره الاولى التي
يعزل فيها مسؤولين حتى على مستوى اعلى
وصلت الى حدود المخابرات وحتى
السفراء في الخارج هذا الامر يعطي الصوره
الواضحه للغرب على ان العتاد والقتال
والذخيره وحتى التدريب هي في ايادي امنه
وهذا امر مهم جدا على الصعيد المعنويات
وعلى صعيد سمعه الجيش الاوكراني في البعد
الغربي خاصه ان الغرب هو الذي يمول
اوكرانيا بكل موضوع اللوجستيه من العسكر
من التدريب من الاليات على كل المستويات
جمال
نشرت حوالي عشره الاف عسكري على حدودها مع
بيلاروسيا كما قالت لدعم الامن على الحدود
المشتركه
ولديها مخاوف من مخاطر محتمله تشكلها
مجموعه ماجنر التي انتقلت مؤخرا الى
بيلاروسيا كيف تنظر الى هذا التحرك الب
ولندي الاخير
هو جزء مهم لتحسين الجبهه الشرقيه خاصه ان
بولندا اليوم تلعب بحلف الناتو وكانها
راس السهم وهي القوه العظمى اليوم في
اوروبا الشرقيه
مقاتلين مقاتلينر حسب العدد لا يشكلون
خطرا ولكن اذا تراكم هذا العدد ولا يجب ان
ننسى جمال ان بولندا هي الممر اللوجستي
للحرب الاوكرانيه وهي التي تقع وهي الفاصل
بين بيلاروسيا واقليم كلا نيجرات وهنا تم
الحديث عن ممر سوىلك المهم الاستراتيجي
هذه كلها تحضيرا للسناريو السيء عله يبقى
السيناريو الجيد العميد الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجيه المتحدثا من بيروت سيد
العميد شكرا لك على الافاده